on va parler de kim kardashian la vue du
cul partons un peu dans le chic alors
ses incarnations alors c'est l'un de ses
petits amis ses anciens à petit à petit
ami donc annexes c'est le rappeur reggie
que daniel me reconnais bien avec qui il
a fait une sextape que d'humour n'a pas
fait
donc il a fait des révélations
croustillantes dans the sun qui est un
magazine à peu c'est un peu chez un peu
le vôtre c'est public là-bas quoi c'est
ça un peu sinon ça marche beaucoup là
bas c'est une j'ai compris en mai j'ai
compris guillaume et ça m'agace ce que
je vois dans un enregistrement dont elle
s'est procurée donc je sonne on apprend
que kim kardashian aurait dépensé 75
mille dollars a donc 65000 euros pour
s'offrir un sextoy qu'elle a une
connexion intime de sexton qui rangeait
dans un homme dans une malle louis
vuitton voilà il révèle également des
bus propres et vous pourrez les
commenter des détails voilà sur son
intimité
on a eu du bon temps des séances de
marathon intensive elle adorait faire
l'amour mais ne voulait pas transpiré
donc elles s'arrêtaient pendant qu'elle
faisait l'amour pour se remaquiller un
petit peu oui pour se remaquiller bah
quoi écouter voilà c'est normal elle ce
film les connu pour ça au lit elle était
déchaînée nous dit il
voilà il explique qu elle aurait dépensé
près de 100 mille dollars aussi pour du
fil dentaire tout ça est quand même très
très étonnant voilà donc et apprendre à
ce sujet sur les caprices de star est ce
que ça vous ça vous surprend tous à
aller voir peut-être qu'il en parle ou
qu'elle soit comme ça je sais pas fx est
ce que ça vous surprend ou pas
catherine mais pour moi il kardashian
savez c'est les tuche vous avez vu ce
film qu'on a c'est une touche dans
calais dégoût de tubes et ça m'étonne
pas que l et d'égout si bas si je puis
dire mais c'est plutôt serais jy qui
fait de sextape avec elle ya dix ans qui
ce cap d'agde est connue elle était
connue comme ça et lui un peu cher il a
pas réussi est connue derrière et du
coup derrière ils vénèrent parle il dit
un peu n'importe quoi parce que d'y un
string à cent mille enfants c'est pas si
intéressant que ça en fait
donc tu sens que le titre ba pardon
c'est de savoir que les tabloïds
rabelais en plus payent beaucoup de gens
pour parler et que du coup il a pris un
chèque pour dire un peu des choses il
fallait bien qu'ils racontent des
détails pas d'intégrer n'importe quoi
bon se trouver à ses souvenirs les
mérites les plus scabreux pour les là je
donnais à part parce que pour elle c'est
un peu c'est comme si deux c'est comme
si jean d'ormesson de paris de victor
hugo
magali garde à kim kardashian mais voilà
avec tout l'amour que je te par
catherine excuse moi mais tu vas pas me
dire quand même que le ski est très
basse et comme seul le niveau de ce gars
là tu vois se dire c'est d'aller parler
sont des ébats sexuels qui a eu il ya
longtemps déjà on s'en fout et
deuxièmement c'est une cible facile les
kardashian on sait que qu'on s'attache
aux 15 h ans on va la faire passer un
peu pour une cruche et c'est ça
à cent mille euros mais persuasion à ça
mais on a dit c'est une pêche c'est
quand même pas quelqu'un d'assez oui les
bonnutiens mais non l'image est ici
magali tapas te tutoie trois filles qui
a pas envie qu'elle faisait avec kim
carbone qui veut des enfants est bien
pire la soeur de mme exemple c'est la
même question que tu m'a posé à trois
c'est donc ça prouve que la réponse
d'eads est pas clair à mes enfants n'ont
pas l'âge d'or semble à kim kardashian
pas ce taux de réponse non mais attends
daniel l'a opposé à vendre oui en même
temps moi je suis assez d'accord avec
magali on la traite de tubes de voile a
depuis complètement débile enfin chez
grâce à cette nouvelle elle a réussi à
monter c'est juste énorme et je pense
que pour monter un tel business faut pas
être si débile que ça pour l'argent
là pour le coup c'est hier qu'on va
avancer sur des caprices de stars sont
pas faits réunion sur le fil dentaire
quand même deux mois ces secteurs centre
5000 euros j'aimerais bien voir ce sont
des gens millionnaire mais au-delà de ça
ça reste des valeurs totalement cheap
c'est contradictoire mais ils sont chip
ils sont totalement artificielle et
c'est vrai qu'ils sont suivis par
tellement de personnes s'adonnent pas
mes valeurs et vous avez tout une grave
c'est pas que kim kardashian est ce que
le plus grave c'est qu'elles existent
comme ça où est-ce qu il ya autant de
personnes qui la suivent c'est ça le met
on la regarde pour s'en moquer on la
suit pour s'en moquer